how do we adopt an internal locus of
control so that we can start feeling
motivated all of the time well they
found that the best way to do so is by
simply solving problems in your own life
and then taking some time and
appreciating the fact that it was your
actions that solved this problem I'll
give you an example just to make things
more clear let's say you're someone who
struggles with falling asleep so you go
do some research and you find out if you
get some more sunlight in the morning if
you only use your bed for sleeping and
if you install a blue light filter on
your phone that should drastically
increase your ability to sleep faster
when bedtime comes around you do all of
those things and lo and behold you find
yourself sleeping 15 minutes faster than
before when you notice this Improvement
you need to say to yourself wow it was
because of the changes I made because of
the effort I put in that I am now able
to sleep better it's that simple build
up that belief that you are in control
of your destiny that you have an
internal locus of control and you will
never have issues with motivation in
your life again